this is we are entering uh a new kind of
what's the right word neo it's
neo-futilistic in a sense there's a
noble class there's the the modern
landed gentry and that is to say a few
things
we were just talking about you know you
can't call youtube you can't call
twitter you can't call google okay uh
well i can
because uh this is the way that the
society is starting to function that you
have followers you have notoriety then
all of a sudden you find out that people
are calling you and you have email
addresses and they're they're here for
you all of a sudden you find out that if
you get bad service on an airline and
you've got ten thousand followers well
you might get a response but what's that
you got a hundred thousand followers oh
now you're flying first class and
they're apologizing you got a million
followers and now you're on that global
concierge list
this is where we're going so for me uh
actually
for other people
i get i get messages from people and
they say hey yo tim i had a video get
you know d monetized do you have any
idea like what i can do to get it fixed
and i'm like honestly i don't you can
try tweeting at you know team youtube
they try to get things sorted and uh
fairly effective for a lot of people
interestingly social media is an easy
way to connect so now we know they're
handling we can send them a message and
they can see it and some of these
channels are moderately large
when i get demonetized i hit up google i
send an email right away and they say
sorry about that no problem we got you
set you got your sword right away
sometimes they go like we're not giving
you this one for this or that reason
when the alex jones episode got taken
down
so here's here's the first thing
i hit up google and i said
are there any people that we have like
that are outright no-no's for youtube
like you would ban us for simply having
he said no and i was like so you know
here are the people where we would like
to have on the show and they're like
absolutely no problem and then i said
okay and then they take the episode down
and i ask them why and they say we won't
tell you so i'm like so i have no idea
what they're taking down so it's not not
everything this is what i'm talking
about by the way like right not but not
but
i'm actually talking to them on the
phone i'm on the phone saying you can't
even tell me what we did and they're
like we don't know because the people
who chose this were higher up than we
are we are so it's like it's it's it's
almost like this new feudalist thing
where
they they are creating classes of people
the average person you can have your
account maybe will ban you a lot of the
accounts that are getting banned and
getting censored are small and this is
why
you don't see it in the media the left
likes to say cancel culture isn't real
because these celebrities still are rich
or something but what they don't realize
is that 90 of those who got suspended
and deleted for a political opinion were
someone with 50 followers or 100
followers and now they're ip banned they
can't get back on the service and
they're like okay whatever i guess
so the low the the lower class
individuals in terms of the social
hierarchy the social credit score
whatever they're building will have no
access to facebook we'll have no one to
message we'll simply say please and
they'll say
bugger you know bug off we don't care
and then the people who have prominence
are are given
access it's it's a combination of
they'll look for you to make sure
they're they're they're you know they're
worried about your social influence but
also when it comes to facebook
i know people like i know people in the
news industry and they say here's the
email you need tim don't worry about it
regular people don't have that so now
we're seeing this weird world where
people are desperate to have followers
because it makes them feel like they
could finally get access to systems and
be treated fairly
yeah i will say also when i mentioned
coming from like the sales or trading
floor space there are a whole variety of
platforms i mean back in the day it was
a manta lead 4-1-1 so on instant
checkmate works well now where you can
pull up the contacts for the executives
at most companies including some of the
social companies like when we got
genuinely irritated at twitter we
started i mean i started doing that um
so i mean you can look at ipo filings
you can look at who the listed
executives online are i mean it's
possible to contact at one point i
called mark cuban during a job at the
company marcus evans like all that
stuff's easily available like you can if
you do get one number you can call into
the company and just sort of dial off
seven's the mail room you know i had
this number on a corporate reference for
jack dorsey look i don't have a lot of
time to waste here can you tell me what
his number is don't need to sell a
secretary's fine whatever and it works
nine most of the people i've known that
have a similar financial background
haven't had a lot of issues with these
companies but of course i mean to some
extent this is just saying what you're
saying like yeah you're a stock broker
for 10 years you'd probably get in touch
with them too you know
again there there are two levels here
one it's generally not that hard to
break the rules or the law and not get
caught at the most basic level like if
your ip band i mean which is a real
thing like you can just download tor and
your ipl be fiji if you have 50
followers on twitter it wouldn't be hard
to get back on twitter and be a troll
frankly um but again the question is
should you have to do that i'd prefer to
see when we talk about politicians
potentially regulating these brands or
sparring back and forth with them one
thing that i would like to see is just a
common sense demand that these rules be
illustrated what does this mean what is
hate speech what do you mean you can't
tell me who my prohibited guests are
this happens all the time well there's
no prohibited guests but they won't tell
me what was said that got the video
flagged and now we can only make
assumptions about what we think was
actually said and so when i said to them
listen we'll we'll make clips from the
show and we'll remove whatever you said
was against the rules and they said we
won't tell you and i'm like well
what do you want me to do you got to
keep in mind they all have the ability
to ban anyone at any time as per their
terms every social media site has that
in their terms
that's got to change it's time for uh
some will will chamberlain's got it he's
a smart fella yes he knows i uh when
dave got suspended he said dave should
go into a courtroom get an injunction
get his account turn back right on turn
right on i think i think you're gonna
see people starting to do that it's the
same thing as there was an entire um
genre of legal cases in the 80s and 90s
as you guys probably know where people
started talking about non-traditional
property like the right to receive
welfare benefits if welfare happened to
be legal in their state and it's the
same thing here like do you have some
right not to have what is it dave at
three four million followers and your
financial livelihood taken away on a
whim i'd be interested in seeing what a
judge says about that i mean there there
has to be some element of contracting
there i mean has he entered into an
advertising deal with youtube or twitter
has he ever made them a dollar because
then i mean you have what is it offer
acceptance consideration i mean dave
dave just launched a book and they
suspended him
i believe it was when his
around the same time his book is coming
out okay i i'll say straight up if this
was the day his book was coming out they
suspended his account
that he should take the first hour of
sales
as soon as he was able to promote on
twitter
calculate his losses based on the 12
hours
and then say those are the damages
because he would have been able to say
hey my pre-order's available now here's
my new book tweet they suspended him and
he didn't violate any rules they claimed
he did and not only that i think dave
should file a defamation suit because
they claimed that he put out medical
misinformation but dave was citing the
washington post and i think it was click
or land i'm not sure what the other side
even cnn it was cnn in washington post
and he's like what did i i posted these
these articles like it was it was a
statement based on this they claimed it
was misinformation in which case that's
a false statement of fact so he should
at least try to sue and the damages are
that his new book is coming out and
they're shutting down his his means for
promotion this is this is a platform
where people pay to get access to share
information so if dave has built up that
access which creates the content which
drives advertisement to the platform
they i i think it's time people start
firing off these lawsuits saying you
can't do this but they're allowed to ban
anyone at any time he's he signed that
terms of service when he writes an
account but we don't understand is i'm
arguing that
that has to change and it changes with
suing
so precedent would be set for instance
twitter defamed dave rubin
see one of the problems they have is
that they could have just said no reason
we banned them for fun and they may
start they do they should they've done
it to other people they've they've
suspended people and put no reason at
all they just it's just like you've been
suspended for blank with dave it was
misinformation i i believe it was
you know i don't get sued either but i
believe it was misinformation i could be
wrong and uh dave could say that's just
factual not true um james o'keefe is
suing specifically because they claim
good i'm not surprised by that right he
was i mean he's the master of it they
said he was operating multiple accounts
so he said that's fake that's that's a
lie it's a false statement of fact and
i'm going to sue you and not and that
was a big mistake because now we can go
for discovery and get internal
communications on what they've said
about him and
his his his organization so
dave shitsu
yeah that the the one question by the
way in terms of your point i think it's
a good one when you say well they
they're saying that they can get rid of
you for the legal language would be any
reason or no reason at all so even if
you sue and you prove that that you were
defamed you might get some money damages
but they can still likely keep you off
the site i think the issue there is is
that what's called an unethical adhesion
contract like can you sign a deal
with a company that is going to give you
the chance to make tens of millions of
dollars where they can take all of your
money and all of your followers away at
any time i don't i mean i
law schools a while ago but i would have
some real questions about whether you
can i would have some real questions
about now that these sites are growing
into serious businesses whether you can
do some of this junior varsity crap like
for no reason given remove someone from
your platform permanently and take their
entire follower account away that sounds
very questionable i mean that that's
going back to like the early days of
facebook when people had 100 friends
not only that but there's
there's there's an expectation based on
the rules they set so of course they say
you can be terminated for for any reason
we reserve that right but there's still
an expectation that
these are the rules you have to follow
and so long as you follow them you are
within bounds of being on the platform
they've broke no rules yeah but they
don't you don't need to break rules to
get booted off those things
right so the issue is is it an unfair
contract definitely are you are am i if
i said to you ian you can you can you
can come here and you know do all this
work and then uh uh you know have a
great opportunity and so long as you
don't say a naughty word you're fine and
then one day after you've you've been
working here for a long time i just kick
you out the door and you're like but i
didn't break in yourself it doesn't
matter it's my house like a right what
is a right to work state what i mean is
it there there are certain contracts
that are unenforceable right so uh
non-competes in many states i don't know
if you you went to law school you said
yes yeah like non-competes are
unenforceable in out of states right
it's my understanding yeah so the there
are contractual terms that are generally
not enforceable um on open non-compete
clause extending beyond a certain short
period of time often is i'd have to look
at the case law but the issue here i
think would be more what's called an
adhesion contract where if you sign a
contract with a player like your camera
company when you when you look at the
back of the box of a piece of tech
equipment that in the terms and
conditions go on for 16 printed out
pages in a couple situations i've seen
and at the end you check your x and you
submit if that contract were to include
something like if this piece of
equipment breaks you owe us a thousand
dollars or something completely
ridiculous that wouldn't be enforceable
because it would be understood that
that's nonsense that the person with
more power put into the text of the deal
like that would be disputed as very
unsympathetic and i think i don't know i
actually think your point's a really
good point but i i think social media
my actual reaction is come on bro it
can't work that way like even with me at
like 40 000 plus maybe like 20 000 on
different other platforms like
that's i've been absolutely my books
have made bestseller lists like it if
you were just to say okay we're going to
take these 60 000 people away and we're
going to set up some kind of permanent
ban so that you i mean i could or you
could easily but the average citizen
couldn't get back on the platform that's
just total bs like it's you having the
power position in the contract doing
something that's probably illegal so
like i couldn't sign a contract with
like tim couldn't sign a contract that
says if you want to work here and be say
a video engineer i get to punch you in
the face twice a day because it would be
a manipulative use of power physics i
got a better example i couldn't say ian
you can come work on the show and
to work on the show you obviously have
to be in the house and i can evict you
from the property without notice at any
time
that's actually against the law
right
so when it comes no it literally is it
is because there's a there's a separate
law that regulates eviction in every
state not to jump that's actually a
solid point and that that actually kind
of gets to the point here like are there
other laws for example that product
protect against say undo deprivation of
income is a claim you might be able to
bring like if a company just says
like any company could do this like i
just got a fairly new vehicle could
mercedes or bmw say something like if
you miss one payment on your car loan or
better yet if you miss
one maintenance trip for your vehicle we
take the vehicle back can you just say
any kind of ridiculous thing in a
contract when you're selling a product
someone else really needs not often no
not only that but typically
repossessions are forfeiture so if you
have a car and you don't pay your your
loan payment for two months they may say
we're gonna move to repossess the car
because you're delinquent typically it's
not usually two months you can actually
just tell the repo guy it's my car you
can't take it i'm challenging this as a
civil dispute and they can't take it a
lot of people don't know that so the
repo guy shows up and they go okay and
their book says you got it and that's
that's that's the game they play in fact
you can just call the police and say i'm
in a civil dispute you can't take my
property and they'll say that's right
you can't
so in this instance i wonder if you know
you mentioned about undo deprivation of
income
i think the eviction thing is is an
interesting point there may be laws that
people haven't haven't haven't looked at
or realized that you're entering into an
agreement that grants you some kind of
access to a system so it's it's almost
like at the very least
we created laws to protect tenants for a
reason and maybe we can view social
media accounts as us as tenants on a
platform we are using it to run a
business considering a lot of the
economy is now digital especially with
the way youtube does super chats and the
way people run their business on these
digital platforms we are effectively
tenants of these these platforms and we
have a contractual agreement but they
can evict us without notice immediately
hey man when you have a business or a
house you at least get 30 days and you
can file a suit to argue why they can't
do this to you now dave rubin can can be
on this platform creating entertaining
content and informative content that
builds up an audience on the platform
that makes them money
providing a service to them
and then without notice without due
process they kick him off for a false
reason and defame him in the process
imagine if your landlord came to your
house and you you had a pizza shop and
they put up a big sign saying this pizza
shop puts dookie in their pizza and then
called the cops and the cops came and
kicked you
we gotta remove defamation just for the
argument's sake because
they can remove you for no reason so and
i think that's worse i'm saying
specifically in the case of dave rubin
equate it to if dave was running his
business in a physical location he'd
have legal protection one day they just
evicted him without notice one day dave
walks to his pizza shop and he shows up
and the building's empty and all of his
stuff is out in the street
soaking wet in the rain or they would
keep the stuff i mean the stuff you make
at that in their job is youtube's
content i mean as far as i know yep
this is youtube's video right now right
better better yet better yet dave walks
one day to his pizza place to open up
but you know he's got to get there at
9am because they open up for the early
lunch and all of his equipment has been
crushed and mutilated and destroyed and
it's a permanent destruction of
everything he's built and everything of
value because twitter followers and
accounts do have a market value it's
been calculated by companies companies
pay money for the equivalent of reach
and they say to him the lease said we
can do whatever we want we have laws
saying you can't do that for obvious
reasons because this would it's
disruptive to the economy as we're
moving into a digital economy how can we
have that people build their business on
youtube monkey jones deserves a shout
out whenever this happens monkey broke
no rules monkey made monkey jones had a
channel he had 300 something thousand
subscribers it was his business it was
his life he dedicated years to building
that business and he broke no rules he
was given no warning and everything was
destroyed overnight at the very least i
understand the argument they say in
their contract they can do it well
certainly there should be a law saying
they can't because it's un it's it's
undue deprivation and it's a victim
without no we need a monkey broke no
rules shirt
that's a great phrase monkey broke no
rules he broke i don't know anything
about this guy though
i'm googling he made a lot of really
edgy content and uh he
pushed the envelope in a way but it was
not much he didn't break the rules those
people are tough as a as an admin those
people are tough to deal with when they
when they get around the rules that's
why we put in clauses it mines anyway we
can remove anything at any time but
people would be so snaky with with the
rules to get the most disgusting stuff
in front of people in front of kids it's
crazy so i will say that it's it's
arguable that the content he made was
distasteful to a lot of people
but how about they just say hey guy this
one video you made we're going to take
it down but then he did it over and over
no they didn't do that they banned him
without even giving a single strike one
day all of a sudden his channel was just
gone and they banned a second channel
which was like anime reviews or
something it was brutal wow it was
brutal i understand the strike system i
understand the warning system if you see
three plus strikes at once you ban the
account up right instantly they got
three strikes this guy back on a bunch
of edge social media is simeon jimmy and
doing better yeah okay probably yeah but
but monkey jones aka simeon jimmy right
the first hit is his wikitubey of fandom
there people are loving this guy from
space to erase to my story is monkey
jones
he broke no rules imdb
so he had if kong loses i'm going to
let's say end it all okay i see the
issues here
finally leaking my all of my dms okay
so he he he was making edgy content
about an individual i'm not gonna name
who's a despicable individual and it
didn't break any of their specified
rules and they didn't even just
like how about this here's an email hey
um look we understand you know this is
the kind that you produce here are the
terms we've set forward we're asking you
right now
don't do these things otherwise we'll
have to ban you
and he would have said yes the same
thing with with carl benjamin i said
this when patreon banned him i was like
patriot uh patreon banned carl without
warning overnight because of something
he said on a live stream like a year
prior and if they just gone to him and
said hey we saw that you were on a
stream and you said these things
it causes problems for us because we're
getting a lot of bad press we'd
appreciate if you if you wouldn't do
this carl would have been like all right
i don't want to lose my patreon so you
know no problem but they didn't they
just nuke his income instantly thanks
for checking out this clip from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to see the
full show come back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time